good afternoon we ever why and it's
really my honor to be here
q for professor Harris and Lolita and
make me the this link connected with the
richer thank you for you but invited
meet here well for a pastor like 18
years have been working in China for few
growing companies doing business in
China so today I trying to come over
here talk about the my perspective view
of the business landscape in China and I
will my my home I go is that they'll
give you more the inside story about how
to run a business environment and that
sort sort of things based on the
practice practice practice reasons since
I've been there for many years and I
would start off to talk a little bit
introduce myself a little bit actually I
came to United States in 1986 at that
time I applied for graduate school
basically I studied in physics I got my
PhD in physics from Montana State
University I don't know how many of you
heard about that and the day after that
working quite a few universities like
Wisconsin Pittsburgh for years then I
decided not stay in the Academical field
anymore so I kind of start up a little
business so start from 1997 to 2002 I
start up a couple company us in Urbana
Champaign Illinois where I used to live
and the thing I had a partnership with
one of my friends who is from MIT we
co-founded the company called Boston
instrument for that company we majored
in to the medical equipment and the name
is the MRI and applying some local
hospitals from 2002 to 2007 I kind of
decided go back to China to looking for
some opportunities there so we set up a
subsidiary company of the Boston
instrument we cost Shanghai
the instrument and we research and the
developers medical equipment and the
major market that will use the mainland
China during that time I also started a
company called AHA and they're trying to
do some business like for a smart home
integration type of the product well
that was the time I spent about five
years and to start with some company the
truth under seven and the tooth under 13
I pretty much have done a lot of their
working the reason fair for some local
private company in China the reason for
that is there are SBI could acquired
about one of the company named EAN which
is the large private company in China
and what they do is to do the gas
distribution for quite a few cities so
there are big company and they're in
energy sectors we joined the year and
then we did a quite a few project that
gave me a lot of experience how to do
business globally so first thing I did
is that therefore one project is called
coal underground coal gasification
which means the burn the gas and the
ground and Acadia gas out of the errors
then used for infrastructure reasons so
that project inside was in Inner
Mongolia of in China which is quite cold
areas there I spend about a year to work
on that project later we acquire a
company from which big star which is the
Middle East area so I work as the board
director there for about a year and
gives some different experience about
those regions and the later they we
start a very huge project what we call
en solar installer is that we use some
high technology we call flat panel
manufacturer technology to
utilize that for the solar panels for
photovoltaic and the we partnership with
the a plant material which is the
Silicon Valley company and the D provide
us with the equipment we build up the
manufacture facility and the research
back in China for that energy we didn't
hit the right time because right after
we started production then financial
crisis started so with investment over
it's about 200 meaning us donors for
that project and didn't turned out that
has any result so later I said what I
can do about that so I went to the
Europe because at that time that's a
market place so we start up the company
we call here in Europe and we trying to
build a power plant so that's really
shift me from manufacturer into the
application from the technology into the
intro like a utility company type of the
business so I did about a 1 and 10
megawatts of the power plant in Germany
and also in Italy and later on what I
was the headhunting by one of the
company called GCL I think AGCO is the
largest acidic in company and they
provide a silicon material for the
photovoltaic applications one of yours I
think one of my colleague used to come
to this class to talk about their
renewable energy sections I work has the
VP for technology development basically
just give the roadmap about how the
solar business can growing and what kind
of application we can implemented so
later the start of the business is
correr IDI and they invested quite a lot
of money and which is new suto
is near Shanghai and that project only
lasts about a year so but I learned a
lot of they experienced about how to
make a connections between different
section of that industry so pretty much
that that time is that I did quite a few
of those the business practice in some
big companies later on during that time
we also cool for my personal near
co-founder company with my brother and
that company was covered in 1997 so
during that time in 2009 we moved the
company from Champaign to sent in the
company is called the Moodle so we found
that company there in 2012 I said this
business could mean pretty big so I come
back to this business I kind of in
charge of the business development and
the technology management and also in
charge of the finance and raise some
money and I peel the sort of things do
you notice the past six years I really
did a lot of the entrepreneur startup
works for example I set up there
our John Hsu facility which is the quite
big facility we got a piece of land and
the Builder manufacturers and that took
us about one year to get that finish
another thing is that we set up a R&D
center in bay area in Freema and which
doing their R&D and the operations also
we set up the back to Europe and did a
sail subsidiaries and Australia - so
anyway look at them my background seems
cover quite a lot of things and good
thing is that I really accumulator of
some of the business business experience
where bad thing is that my English is
getting not as good as you used to be so
I just trying to speak slowly and trying
to make myself understood and I also
just very
informal talker so you have some
questions during my presentation just
tell me we can go from there
this is their basically my personal
background think I'm going to do a
little bit the commercial slides about
the water my current company which i
co-founded and that the company called
the modem and a meteor basically we have
a to business identity wine school the
modem was commissioned and what we do is
that we make all kind of devices used
for home in-home application like
surveillance like a smart living like
energy management and that kind of
application so we produce variety of the
devices and all the devices are
connected into a cloud so the new
business is called IOT platform so in
2012 we start to develop the platform
ourselves we called me here and that
platform is pretty much served for all
the devices we connected and a little
profile about our company we have a
currently they have about their 650
employees and last year our revenue I
think is about 95 meaning Westerners so
we kind of grew in like very pretty fast
it's about 60 percent per year
up to today I think we have about 4.5
mini devices which year most of them are
manufactured by us and are connected and
we have about 1.5 meaning customers
majority of the customers in us also we
have our devices since we sell globally
we have covered about their 40 countries
last year we built up ITC Center in
Champaign Illinois and that's a huge
capacity so all of our data or in-store
our own ITC centers the fraud part we
have produced is pretty much from like a
video camera and the used and different
locations in tow Alto front door and
currently we see a lot a lot of the one
of the product Autopia smart appeal
which were identified who coming to your
house
and the second the category of our
product is like a smart living product
like you have your backyard irrigation
systems which will automatically manage
your backyard like a grass and when
you're open water rain also we have a
third category what we core is the
energy meter which is the thermostat and
also we we produced one of the core
smart finding which will automatically
sensor with the recipe for live there
how to turn that off
we're closed a windy and you save some
energy bill every device is pretty much
have them different sensors are
connected or the analytical work and the
application work has been done in the
cloud so this the major business model
for the platform which will spend about
yes energy so how did you choose to
start okay
this is since our ginger it's very quick
question I'm Sheena I'm going to talk
about in the last section is the why I
wanted to business as how to drive it's
like a their purpose of a running
business to answer is that I want to
build up their brand name companies so
anyway this our platform our platform we
start to research and develop it in from
2012 this prep platform is very open and
pretty much any device is the
home use can be connected leads through
the crowd your appliances refrigerators
or some other stuff you can connect it
there so connectivity is very important
and then we want every devices has its
own applications
so we base them what's the environment
and experience and we do sort of they're
like a security surveillance we
automatic know who come to your house
whether there's some alarm you to be pay
attention to and in the central part of
this platform we have a lot of the like
a I initiated cloud technology ability
so that were automatically sensor or
occasions the current application
actually only used in this to field is
like a security and a smart home for
user side since our IPP platforms were
open pretty much and the user can use it
developer key develop your own AP piece
also you can generally a lot of the
business through this kind of openness
and you probably know that it currently
like a Google and Amazon are pretty much
getting to this industry this our data
center in Champaign
we have about the one one thousand pick
by a 100 pig beds of capacities and
currently we have one for my meaning
customer for this capacity can serve
about the 2.5 million customers so we
plan ahead a little bit anyway that's a
little bit bad commercial but our
company actually today here really I
want to hear some perspective you from
my personal experience on the ground you
send a and the some part of other part
of the China I think I'd look at a web
site of this class there was a
presentation goodbye Chris Perry I went
through those his presentation
the three-term which had thinking really
fade into what I want to talk about so
it's time to sense that what kind of the
class as you get I like the word they
used for climate and the soil and the
nutrients and the thing I'm going to in
today's talk I'm going to talk a little
bit about what's climate business
climate in Shenzhen and other city then
I will talk about what's his soil and
the major Nia focused on was the
nutrients because this define you can
have a variety of the definitions what's
the good for your for startups
I will ended up with some suggestions
then we get into Q&A anyway I don't know
how many of you heard about a world
called China PE area which is the
proposed about couple years ago what the
Chinese government is trying to build up
an economical zone that will compete
with the some current big rooms so
currently we have a Tokyo we have a San
Francisco Bay Area have in New York and
this some demographic data does about
this regions so in China the proposed
the this room which covered about there
one one-fifth of the condom privacy and
what the core Guangdong
Hong Kong and Macau Bay Area which
covered about there 56 56,000 square
kilometer which is quite a big and also
has a 1.3 trillion GDP which is very
small compared to some other Bay Area
bridges but the population is quite big
and has about the 66 million people
there you know sensing is right in the
center of this new Bay Area
some things is very interesting is that
you know sensei is the city this is some
comparison between those two at this for
Pierrot datas like a GDP per capita New
York seems ahead and the in San
Francisco and Tokyo and then this bear
is only a different fraction of that but
they are growing very fast something
about the sins in this city I know a lot
of student from singing when in Stanford
and I can corner some numbers and the
one memorized core most startups in
China so if we wanted really to do
startups I think a same thing is the
first one to attract the people to do
startups the reason I will talk later
and the second one the sensei I mean for
past 10 years still the youngest city in
China the average age is like at 33
years old so very young and the other
part of the China has to kind of over
age the problems while changing still
have it's a prosperous young people work
there of course GDP is highest in in
China if you talk about the city and
growing rate here for about 30,000 per
capita actually screen about 27% over
previous year is very fast
two things I want to emphasize is the
pub patent the patent application China
I think am all assenting covered about
the total of 14 percent and the which is
more than any other cities if we look at
it by cities this highest one that tell
us is that if you are running the high
tech knowledge a Chinese engine has a
good climate and soil and the nutrient
that's why passive most of there
pattern of Pliny the second part is
capriciously patent applications which
tells us this is also covered about 41%
of the nationwide that tells me is that
the Shenzhen is trying to be doing a
globalization process so really their
product are shipped all over the world
and that's goo museum could give us some
hint about that and now let's get into
the climate how many new startups every
day you same thing I didn't know this
you know I've been working changing it
through different different air level of
the I was in some kind of advice
advisory board for some like a city and
some industry and that even realized
that many startups you know in 2017
there's about half meaning of startup
registered in each engine and every day
they register over like 15,000 new
startups so if I convert that into per
1000 the populations this accumulated
now we have 87 incorporated companies
among 1000 populations and we have a 266
other business entity have open
restaurant coffee shop and everything so
that's a huge number also there's the
one high-tech licensed entity this is
very important one because if you are
granted by government as the
high-technology
search certified company you take a lot
advantage to get their governmental
subsidies I will talk that later
also total I appeal you Sanjay is the
389 and the last year alone has about
the 160 so if we talk about this couple
years and the change a really convert
from Lois
oh ye and hub for hardware into more
innovative cities this is the overall
climate soil since I kind of live in Bay
Area for quite many years so I know this
is the world-class place there's a place
that everybody dreamed to and there's a
variety of the startups in Bay Area has
the most advanced advanced the
investment the mechanism as you can
easily fight and you can find there some
visas so found is very available here
also the most important is that they
have a world-class stand here and you
know I graduate from junior University
back in China many years ago and we have
a core Chinua do not here or something
we have about 3,000 student alumni here
here in Bay Area which hitchhike there I
think it some other countries I think is
the same so most advanced especially
take technical talent or attract into
Bay Area so that's a huge advantage and
this part here and they also a I talked
a little bit about Kong are trying to
find what's what's not good for startups
I remember about three years ago when
our solar company had subsidiary here
we're trying to develop one product core
microing convert inverter then we come
up with design and get our layout work
and the boss back in China understand
that in high in three months to get
into our applications we look all of the
places trying to do that and they didn't
find any company I shortest the time
they proposed to us is like a three
month so that's something really lack of
the hardware engineering especially for
electronics industry which will take a
much faster faster pace so also has the
cost of living I'm not going to talk
about the shinden from my experience
that I think they really some o mindset
talk about Shenzhen impression it's like
a copycat it's like in Chinese work for
Sunday and so you can find any chips any
product in Watchung market pretty much
everything but for past few years I have
witnessed a lot of change from those
like Oh yet or rented a manufacturer in
today core hardware innovations and this
really is has the kind of ecosystems
which can let the people to produce that
they're very simple very easily so
that's why convert that into their like
a world-class hardware manufacturer
ecosystems and I read some paper about
so for electronics section here 50 less
than fill liberal close to 50% of the
product are more or less related to
Shenzhen either designed it or developed
by some companies in J or manufacturer
there so the course engine the capital
of electronics hardware's and for past
the two years has the gas engine trying
to convert from a hardware to software
part so a lot of software startup has a
very good soil you can take a lot of
advantage
from my company actually when we first
set up a research center one we our
research has two sections wine score
hardware design another wine score
software and the platform to them so we
couldn't do that in Shenzhen that was
the 2012 so we set up office in Beijing
and because they all the time people in
Beijing are in the software development
engineers up to last year we gradually
transfer our Beijing operation or send a
unit and we shrink down little bit about
Beijing operations the reason for that
is just the more make more business
sense another part of that is we concur
there some talent people are willing to
move from Beijing to Shenzhen so this
has there some advantage if you're you
software startups since he was getting
there not quite yet is not but it has a
lot of advantage about the cons about
the same thing I think innovation is
still somewhere still lacking especially
in the people's mind for example if we
have some old engineers like over 30
years old if you give him some tasks
want to do some development in their
mind they always trying to memorized
what they have done before so pretty
much want to copy everything from what
their experience from other competitors
that mindset is still there so if we
want to convert that into more
innovative work you have to hire some
young guys they don't know anything
about the history they do much better
than all peoples and also changing still
lack of the global eco grantee so I'm
going to talk that later and the
university is one of the shortest things
they don't have they only have one
sending University and
I think I only have one a room never
famous - the founder of the attention
so the publicity is there but actually
talent is still not enough beside that
those Center and the Silicon Valley
comparison I think in sente if you're
doing some like a hardware innovation or
some marketing China that has as good
place to start in addition to that and
that at the give some numbers here I
think is changing is the one of the top
number one city in China to attract the
foreign high tech company in China my
example is that you know my wife didn't
have much to do so she staying in same
day and join one group this core ass
week cause change a woman international
cloth I didn't realize that cloth she's
been there for 25 years and the
currently they have about 500 members I
just got some number from her is that it
is represent about a 189 country on
Aging's
I mean he's a lot of wives are live
there they enjoyed it and the sense they
have a longest time this day there was
like a 30 years now and the some of
those people are given not second
example our neighbor our neighbors from
Brazil and 20 years ago who went to
China work as a procurement department
for carry for and he said about those
things
he ended up create job and the start
work company and the doing business
doing imports beer and the wines from a
from a Europe and he's been doing that
for 20 years now he has a two kids which
looks more like Chinese but speaking
fluent Cantonese and China
so that tell us that a lot of their
foreign high-tech companies are used to
changing as a hub and last Christmas and
that's Thanksgiving dinner I stayed at
the you same day I was invited to one of
the friends who is the director of Apple
operation which was in you same thing
they have over then I talked to the
people and they said that you sent then
they have Apple that had two unit of
operation when his aren t when is the
operation and the Google aren't the
center also set up the Institute there
too so they track a lot of the foreign
high tech company and the secondly a lot
of big company in China if they want to
change the headquarter or set up their
subsidiaries and they choose sending us
their number one choice every year I
think I think they rank rank quite a
quite a few company or ship or moved to
change a talk about infrastructure I
think they have a pretty good high
technology readiness like internet
finish fishing everywhere and the
broadband speed action is very
reasonable compatible with here they
have a like we talked about they have a
mobile pay a lot of advances stuff so
this is the overall about soil you sent
in yes class University you think that
is likely to change soon particularly
they asked large companies coming in and
doing the water R&D and so on so I'm
going to hook that later you chain about
it you mean oh why there's no University
Stewart out of town info so now I get
into the new chain to define what's a
good nutrient for the startups actually
Chris you use a lot of the
different aspect what I'm mainly talking
about access to finance and the human
capital and some resources and you know
you send Jane I often in heard by some
of the student or friends who want to do
startup in China they always ask how I
be able to get the money and easy to get
money or hurting get money or you have
to use their own money I have one
friends who live here startup companies
in Jane here you run at all his money he
sold his house here this still not
enough money actually if you explore
more about the same thing there's a lot
of the access but has to be very careful
for I'll give some example about that
when our company how we do the
fundraising how to get the equity
investment one thing I want to say is
that then you sent in a really lack of
it like NGO fund and the VC fund it's
pretty much VC fund just behavior like I
said and I can do any investment any
startup I will put money there actually
that's not true
a lot of funds are very like a
short-term they have very restricted
term and conditions and if I notice that
there's a quite a few company funded by
some engineering they didn't know much
about about how to run business ended up
their VC took their business and end up
there still to someone so that's a very
restricted term and condition as a
start-up we should be very careful about
that
also every year like a nine-minute you
and I being a us donor how invested you
send in startups that's quite a lot so
pretty much you can if you are in those
connections or networks is it's very
simple to find their money but depends
on what industry you are in
what business you are
and here is the last year's data about
what money
we'll use the money goal and the mini
journey if you have some technology or
entity and you have like a health and
many Medicare I mean for there quite a
lot of money there and the hardware used
to be like a product used to be easy to
find together
investment investor and this last year
and compared to 2016 theta and this
one's automatically used to be high if
you have a product idea you can easily
to get an investor to invest in your
business for now or the investor go into
the different field but in summary and I
think there's a enough venture capital
to support a start-up in San Jen I'm
going to give the example of their of
what the modem has has achieved beside
all of those investor and there's
another advantage to take especially for
high technology startups you know in
China is always government or rented a
lot of the lucky industry like so you
st. then the government issue a lot of
policy as a start-up to anything you
really can apply I have a one friend who
actually one friend's daughter she moved
here from Michelle hi to Cindy and
she'll flying a lot of benefit from
there and that we she started her own
business very easily for example it's
like office rental space it's not much a
requirement it's just a if you're just
start up you can offline that for a pad
first day three years they can give you
like a 80% of reimbursement so this
thing is that something you have to you
should do some research and the take
advantage of this sort of subsidy a
subsidy programs
the modem has been sending for seven
years for first two years we didn't
really know anything about the
government incentives and like fund
investment until 2015
in other word before 2015 we all used
our own money we did use the investors
money to to build up the structure and
but the sense we have a size of the
business we have some business numbers
so we attract a lot of investors so in
very short time we did about three runs
of the equity investment with total
raised about 80 spy meaning us donor in
three run through private equities and
now that I want to emphasize two things
first thing is that therefore any PE
found they are very restricted term and
conditions so if your business plan you
don't have you you propose you have some
business goals to achieved if you're not
they really trying to beat you up and
they give very strict terms so as a
start-up you'd be very careful about the
number about agreement with the
investors and they don't hurt yourself
by over expect your growth of your
business they are serious a second one
is they I've I will reflect back to the
slides I said change a lack of the legal
guarantees and there's one story about
you know in u.s. or in some other part
of the world when you do talk about
investor has a really serious things
right you talked to several times and
negotiation term ashes go through this
process its NW signing agreement once
you sign you feel awkward
I am rich now but in China you have to
be very careful that they even though
you signed your agreement for the money
is not injected you're not still not
sure yet and the one of the investor
used to trying to invest me and the
hitch signed the contract with me for
about the point about five mini u.s.
donor the end of the his fund has some
problem later and there's no like a like
a payback or anything you just say sorry
you can do it so as a start of my advice
is that if money is not the deposit into
your bank you still have to work on that
and there is not a hundred percent sure
because the legal things you can go
through this biggest lawsuit against
them and that will take a lot of time
and your staffer from those process so
that's my suggestion some of the stock
in the company to these people yes
private equity that's right but it was
not a buyout right I mean no it's not
the main ownership of the company is it
a public company no no no nice not yet
it's still private again yeah still
private company and their their wish
they expect in this company can be IPO
or so they have exit prime so they can
make a fortune right and they especially
couple years ago in China what they
called P they're performing very well
because a lot of IPOs and a lot of
acquisitions there's a mostly Chinese
investors actually it's a very intense
international it's very international
and I know when we have an investor we
have an investor from the US and they
have so the Parana fund right there US
dollar fund R&D fund and one project
they can
a lot of mechanism advanced ones so so
kind of as a follow-up to that or a
follow back to that you were talking
about the availability of financing inch
engine so okay the venture capital is
available if you need it are most of the
companies located in Shanghai and
Beijing and they just come and do the
deals and change them or do you actually
have can we fund this from the Shanghai
and Beijing and businesses and companies
that are doing visa have they opened up
offices in change if it's a big fund
that they have a lot of their core
Shenzhen office they start from the team
the core project here you start to do
due diligence and the business plan sort
of thing then they are getting to their
headquarter okay yeah thank you
second part I'm going to talk about
these bad loans which is the really good
resource reviewers because for equity
investment you really die due to your
share very easily and but loan from a
bank is I used to work in a you know in
the Europe when working in Europe and my
partner has a relationship with their
bank for three generations to support
their family business sir very strong
relationship but in China and the bank
is really treat you like a you have to
have some sort of the personal guarantee
or fixed asset to be able to apply for
that or you can use the government as
the collateral to if you have issue some
high tech certificate or you have a pre
IPL use your IP you here as the chloral
to could be able to get their bank loans
so it's not easy to get but as soon as
you got it that's good money so for
pasture like a three years we've been
working through different banks talk
about our with our business model and
that's
we enter to get about 15 million the
pump tells loans from the bank which is
not really easy to get but a lot of
dishes to do that contribute to that is
we build up our manufacturing facility
in other word we purchase the land
build the facility be able to use that
as a as an asset to collateralize that
those loans so that part if you can get
it as good thing another thing I want to
mention there is that the bank loan the
bank loan is there you know they have
like a two-year three-year we as CFO of
the company we need to budgetary work
for your company's plan you got to be
very very careful where we suffer quite
a lot from there you know Chinese
moaning of manipulated by the government
the government that sometimes depends on
the overall climate they restricted and
some of the loans even though you get
approved but for that month you don't
have they don't have money they don't
have a budget for that saying you won't
be able to get a loan release to your
account and the normally now were much
later than later than what they promised
to you
we have one very terrible experience is
that we build up the engine manufacturer
facility we have about the penvenen yeah
but and actually we're less than 10 min
about a mini loans from the bank which
is do like here next month then CFO is
trying to get money and the paint back
and sorting they say that will take one
week you're getting renewed for next
week I save her okay let's play now for
three weeks so we return the money back
to the bank end up we didn't get the
money until about a month and a half
later so for that month that's the first
time with the way to pay our salary
which we feel ashamed about that
so from that time so whenever to our
budget we really have got to be very
careful about their Chinese their
biggest worry is being able to place our
right if you get stuck with a cash flow
problem like that it's an absolutely
terrible thing especially when you're
growing yeah so that's some advice I
could give you later
anyway we take a sum advantage of the
government subsidy and so every year we
would probably be able to apply for
about a one meaningless toner from
government subsidies and the very
important one is what we call here this
one what we call state-level
high tech service certified and this one
is that if you're in the business for
three years you are involved in some
industry which is the government they
have their list and the you did your
performance work you are applying for
that immediately as soon as you got that
license you get 10% of the tax deduction
which is a huge number for the size of
our company so this is a very important
way this overall the financial financing
in your same thing I think is they're
pretty good okay now I get into the
second part of the new chain about a
human capital this some data some
numbers demographic data about sending
population average age migrates that's
something I want to emphasize that you
know GDP Center from 28 2016 through
2017 I compare that data with Shanghai
Beijing and Hong Kong and that their
largest growing rate is initially a 22%
from 26 data to 27th data
so this is there some numbers another
number which is the advantage in
Shenzhen is how to get a human captors
so in same thing even though there's the
11 million populations and every year
the number still increased but increased
by some meaning of the requirement how
to fit into that the Shenzhen residence
I said so in last in last year about 1/2
mini migrants moving to San Jen because
of those quality of life and didn't talk
about that how good air conditioned air
is and they're also government is the
subsidy which really attracts some
people especially high educated people
and also there's a huge a lot of big
companies in general like tennis ain't
far away the hair color is changing the
higher and they have a lot of position
available so pretty much that back there
a lot of people from Beijing from
Shanghai from all the countries that you
know for this epitaphs meaning every
year those requirement together to be
able to work in Xinjiang look at the
Shenzhen benefit is that you have a high
education so there's a lot of housing
being built a lot of house emanate yes a
lot of housing but there's another
problem to go with that is the pricing
just like a silicon value here is the
highest here
listen number housing price if you look
at a couple years number same day is
cheaper than Beijing and Shanghai now is
the most expensive housing in China not
compared to Hong Kong
so that's it kind of the bad side of the
attracted talent people who come to
Woking sends in and that they read so
that's why government is trying to give
the subsidy subsidy to reimburse and
some of their same lives in the city
yeah that's right for example if you
have a master degree you can you get
more points you apply either for subsidy
or your rent oh you feel money you can
buy the house with there's some
reimbursement so yeah so that attributed
contributed to this half mini Tallinn
people moved from Beijing to send from
other city to changing in my company we
used to have about sixty a software
engineer we just one year we moved in
about twenty of them they actually I
locate from Beijing into st. Jane the
pros is that the quality of life is good
what makes the quality of life in
Xinjiang good okay three things and air
are very important yeah I noticed the
pollution is a lot less than it is in
Beijing you know they have about 300
days of the new skies compared to like a
hundred less than 100 days in Beijing
and the food you said it's like in
aggressively it's all kind of food and
not expensive another sense a lot of
activities especially for the high
educated people they have they organized
a lot of they're like a club
associations and so people really from
all over the world if they feel like
like a home
well that's another big thing is their
slogan
is as soon as you arrive sins in your
sin Denise you feel like you're not have
to adopt the culture and natural thing
to passing school is improving every
year improve qui peut another one which
is not considered as the good
improvement is the hospital hospital
something loop it out there high level
Hospital is not enough to support a can
new environment that's their one reason
but school they've been attracted a lot
of cool school from Beijing to open up
the school in Shenzhen so every
residential area the other one oh the
house price will go with that if we have
a good school district and the house
price increase quite a bit yeah yes one
has family one dozen will there be a
progress to take the one that does not
have a household coming to surgeon and
regulation why is that
I don't think there's the difference but
a lot of them not married and young
people will be there I don't think
there's any years of subsidy for their
children moving or something combination
yeah bring the actually feminist is some
sort of the motivation to drive this
talent move there to send Jen because
the quality of their life and at the
same time they also attract some elderly
people to move into Sunday which is some
rich people from a northern part of
China because they weather the air so
they really those older people are
moving to
changing as well and for for a lot of
programs for different names but it's
sent to sending another really take some
action to work on the older the people
come this time
yeah here at H&M put here the rising
cost of the living witches house major
me really has heard the incentives even
the government put some incentives but
is still not enough to because there you
have to pay for rent give you example
about how much work a lot of rent like a
small efficient engine Nansen which is
their Science Park it's like a twin less
than maybe 200 square foot or something
course is like 4000 RB which is the half
maybe half of their salary and that's
pretty high for for ordinary engineers
so they are God our company has to give
sort of their programs let them choose
if you have this certain degree of
subsidy how much you pay and so they'll
calculate ok even though I have to pay
range in the first year for next year I
go get some reimbursement so that that's
really bad thing about it is the cost of
living so this the half meaning of the
newcomers has high educated a lot of
mahat has the sort of their working
experience so that will cover a little
bit about the lack of the university as
of the new talents people and that's
give those enough people if we have a
position opening one day and then then
next day there they can filled up very
you system easily still ok here's our
example of in our company we have a map
managing how to manage in the executives
and we have 70 executives 19 of them are
from oversea either study who had
working experience average salary is not
low anymore it's about the 30k RMB per
month which is about 5,000 per month
average
and for those Chinese experience the
team's executive teams advantage of that
is that I have a very good execution
skill and very quick I'm going to give
some example later and but it is hard to
find the senior position people to do
that executives for engineering engineer
is the hard part to attract the people
from oversea because Sims or graduate
from the US or stay either in Silicon
Valley or working somewhere I don't go
back to China too often and we have five
of them with overseas working experience
and average that raised about 25 MB per
month and for engineering in China
actually there really if you manage you
will they're very productive they're
really doing outstanding work especially
some young talents and but again talk
about innovation that's bad part well
anyway our company did a lot of the good
things about her keep those talent
people work in a company and we're in
past a few years we stood on top of
there and the Wrangler company with
their lower state employee turn over
rate example of the fast execution we
have we trying to we purchased land in
yen change and the build up a factory
facility and they designed it everything
is like a 20 a two hundred thousand
squirrel skirt food and we need of price
to finish that in by the one and a half
years and before since we're running
business we don't know anything about
the construction so we kind of outsource
this to local construction company to do
that they ended up the government says
no it's not a good idea because they're
the quality and the budget something is
not a really guarantee it's not by
contract again so we hire the one
there's someone with the experiments
that the US government with the
construction project and the he feel
different you know he used to work in
different field and now he became our
manager of the site end up the whole
construction from ground to moving start
to production only take one year and
which I was amazed and this guy by the
way he liked our culture can you choose
to stay in the company he's the deputy
general manager for this position now
and he take a lot of ownership about it
because that we build up here city care
take her business to another thing is
that in the company in the modem and I
think since we're from we have a like a
start from the US so we bring some of
the concept a firm a Silicon Valley
today our new company I think turned out
pretty good for example the working
environment
we ran the pretty high grade office
space we have about 200 people working
that 4,000 a square meter office space
and the every summer in a summertime you
know changing is kind of the hot and a
lot of companies trying to save the
energy gas in our company with investor
some money to replace the old air
conditioning we provide the temperature
I think it's the one or two degrees
lower than our neighbor so that make the
employee feel like oh we work in the
Moodle we have a cool place anyway
that's I think it has to some little
things that were will give them some
sort of the advantage and also you have
to provide us like equity to those
employees and in our company we have
about 100 employees has
our equity so if you have equity in
China Chinese people are very realistic
is that they are taking a lot ownership
from that so that part I think we use
the 10% of family our company share and
distributed to the stand of people
Thursday is a strong company culture
things is that we learn something from
Google from Facebook
few years ago when I visited Google and
my daughter and I went to their toe
meter to get some food and then we went
back to China is okay let's start
providing pro your some food so ended up
there it's a really good position I
think they compared the company food
with the outside food and was there some
other company's food that provided
they're really happy with that and
beside that the food and the dessert in
the afternoon we also have sort of there
a lot of activity like a sports we shall
make us very comfortable and we have a
Tuesday passport team have a when no
Tuesday bad meeting and the Thursday
basketball everyday table tennis I also
personally involved with the competition
with them so it became one top one of
the top ping-pong players I enjoy every
minute the first as a youngster also we
defend some personalized career
development well last year we hire one
guy from this school from Stanford and
the shield got a bachelor degree here
from bio engineering and also master
degree work here for about eight years
and she decided to go back to China we
hire her but her major was not really
fitting to us the reason we're here is
we want to want her to be in charge and
they're called technology development
roadmap and she was not really happy
with what she's doing so later we
personalize what career is she want to
be want to be engineer
I want to be management and then we do
one year plant two year plan and across
this culture stance now she's really
happy and every day is energetic anyway
every week we have sort of the training
program because they're our average of
our company H is like 2027 so a lot of
new student new graduate student so we
have to give them like every week they
have a training to learn new stuffs we
hire a lot of the instructor outside
inside to give them training every week
I think that turned out a pretty good
productive anyway another part of a new
train is the resources I often leave
heard about the complain do we have time
okay alright and there nothing often it
here are some new intrapreneur engine
company about their resources actually I
personally involve a lot of they're like
a local like an industry association
club and that they have a lot of
resources I just point out the two
examples how you can utilize this
resource to take advantage of that one
example is if we have a sum product idea
you want to prod out something learn how
to use the local resource one time I
have a cup of coffee with my brother and
we think about how to how about the
beauty some sort of the device use the
lightbulb has the Camry to Detective
what's happened and provided a power for
that then we had the idea and in later
on we asked only people to lay out of
their PCB and the research plans anyway
outsourcing that into the prototype you
know every week we have a meeting for
supplier Chen Miki and we have quite a
few project are they on the table or the
supplier look at this and what it can do
what it cannot do and into this with
your
present you with their with their
prototype machine and the whole mode
everything through the three days cost
about thirty thousand so this is very
fast
at the same time you know there's a
company called reigning US company is
produced a smart oval and the startup
was there like a Kickstarter and then
they originally planning to do their
father development about one year to
deliver to customer is ended of the body
two and a half years for first
generations and because of the ecosystem
you sent then again like we have a table
every week I have this project you come
to bid you come to bid all the suppliers
sit there you say okay I can do that one
mainly in two days our funding with the
contacts so that's some advantage if
you're a manufacturer section is there a
lot of those sense we should utilize
that again production here we use the
performance to get this non produced and
because of higher chain I'm not going to
put more detail about certainly example
point out here you stay if you have some
business idea I want to do something the
same thing they're safe for accelerators
and incubators there's a lot of them
there we have all kind of resource
provided money provide your engineering
platform you can what the core getting
once you get in you link with the
business environment there but they have
to take new share and success rate for
that after about half year or one year
may about 5% I think you're successful
once you can successful again resource
some good resource some bad resources up
to this point that means they're good
resource for when you get in since you
feel so happy about the business
you achieved then you have to be very
careful about it what to do next
you know when they when our companies
started about their of a full year later
Sims our business of very attractive
we got consulting firms financial
advisor is League advisories come to
your office and says okay I have idea
for you what's your exit plan and it
turned out you want to sell your company
and sometimes 80% of those are wired but
is there a lot of public companies so
that's one of the phenomenal is that
don't think it's a good nominal for some
of the entrepreneur but that's called
exit plan so had to be very careful
making you have to be very determined
what you want in terms of the business
environment so this is the some examples
I point out there's a lot of useless
another resource I think is the not just
for business and even for making like a
decoy term we hire one of the attorney
co-housed attorney from us and the she
he was a single he joins some local
legal the cloth in about three months he
can marry because they're a lot of the
people get together every week they have
their own activities anyway I will wrap
up with some suggestions and I will
start with their some for example here
if you're any one of you want to start
up a company I from my experience that
will give you one advice is that if we
choose to come to Sanjay it's not
everything is good to go to change a you
ask you questions that whether it's the
hardware product use your business idea
if you yes the hardware has a big
advantage if it's judge software or
service then I will you we can discuss
that later and also if you have a sort
of day industry or
did you can choose some government this
subsidy take some advantage of that
another saying Chinese governor really
like is that you have your product the
major market is in China you know China
become a market and not just a producer
so for success of your business I think
if they have your product has market in
China that will make sense and even
better you take more advantage of
resources so this is some question as
such as you asked yourself before you do
startups another question this is
something you know I am either with a
lot of engineering as work as the
entrepreneur and the start of the
company they didn't thinking what they
want so first three question I will
suggest you will ask yourself this
what's your exit strategy because that's
very important why I put that in the
first because the often II you okay
they're affected by some other people
they will change your idea of how to do
the business if you want to sell your
technology that's great that's great
business model in China and also sell
the product dependent of his model or
sell the company or you want to set up
the brand name for me for pastor like 20
years my purpose of doing business is
trying to build a brand name and that's
a long way to go and they were steel
coil itself startups even just past the
seven years those three potentially a
lot of people can change during the
running of the business you can answer
that later but first question I think
you should ask yourself first before you
do I often use some advice for some new
people and when they want to do startups
I said you're not suitable to be with
startups because that's very important
and I witnessed a lot of the examples in
my humor business ventures I will enter
the police they Steve Jobs word
for severance that's what he said
the company was successful or not
successful I was always there some
high-level summary name we go always
questions I'm afraid to say that we
really don't have time for questions in
the formal part of the session I'd like
to ask maybe the most difficult question
and this will be the only one
so you've grown from being a startup
company to competing on a global scale
you've got some really big competitors
how do you stay active and distinctive
and keep your mindset to be
entrepreneurial from now in the future
well that's here it's called follow the
dream you know any sector when you are
want to be brand name especially to say
business model especially for consumer
electronics it's always competitive no
matter what you do yeah but we believe
that in this new technology drive
industry the unicorn the future you
regard it's not going to come from some
old companies like a Google Google is an
old complete broad ok so we want to be
one of that is great ok
you